Again, that's going to, I guess, depend
on the nation and the region we're
talking about because, and here's the
thing. I guess the first thing I'd like
to say is what's happening. Here's the
difference between Islam historically
and Islam today.
>> The continuity is that Muslims are
creating problems. Okay? They did it
historically. The violence and the
intolerance and the supremacism, okay?
And it's happening now in the present.
The difference is historically, like I
said, it was the jihad of force, right?
They had they had no choice and no one
was going to let them in. So Europeans
fought tooth and nail, you know, fight
fight fighting to the death. Now the
problem is, I think you mentioned it
earlier or I don't know if it was you,
Francis, but you talked about Muslims,
how they're very weak right now and uh
you know they're not a they're they're a
weak force. Why are they a problem? And
the answer is because the West makes
them a problem or the specific country
in the west, let's say the UK. Okay. All
the problems that the UK is going
through for an example due to or and not
just UK, much of Western Europe, it's
all self-made. Okay. And you know that
because I can look at an Eastern country
like Hungary and it has none of these
problems. Is that because Muslims tried
to invade Hungary by force and somehow
the Hungarians resurrected John Hunady
and they and they beat them back? No.
They just said no immigration. We don't
want it. And guess what? No problem. So
this is I think the and this is why a
lot of people get upset. I remember I
once wrote an article cuz a lot of
people in the UK were complaining about,
you know, there's an Islamic invasion.
Muslims are invasion. And I basically
said, "No, get your terms right. This is
not an invasion. An invasion is when
people come by force and they're trying
to take it. This is an invitation."
Okay? This is an enablement from your
leaders. So, I think it's very
important. My point is to I like to when
I look at a problem, you know, not not
veer off kind of um in tangents, but get
to the heart of it. And the heart of the
problem today with Europe and Islam,
it's really not the Muslims. I often
give this analogy where like um I say
imagine a enclosure of zebras and I all
of a sudden decides to put a lion in and
lo and behold the lion starts killing
the zebras. Who's really at fault? Me or
the lion? I think it's me. The lion's a
lion. Okay. Lion's going to do what a
lion's going to do? Muslim's a Muslim.
He's going to have the anti-infidel
thing going on, the tribalism that I
mentioned. Okay. But why are they being
brought in with all these massive
numbers? Why are the native Brits let's
say or Europeans in general being their
heritage and their religion and their
cultures being suppressed to make room
for these people in the name of some
sort of amorphous tolerance or you know
multiculturalism which is obviously not
working. So my point is the ultimate if
you want to talk about trajectories it
depends really on the countries and it's
actually in a way easily fixed if the
actual supposedly uh elected
representatives of these various nations
do the will of the people but they're
not and that's really the issue. So I
would tell people you know your Islam
problem is less about Muslims and it's
more about the people who are enabling
and empowering them and bringing them in
against your will. These are the people
who have the same names like you and
they look like you and they are
apparently, you know, ruling in your
name, but they're obviously not. And
it's, you know, it's it's become very
obvious right now. So, I think people
should look at the ultimate source of
the problem. Islam is a problem
intrinsically. You can say that, but now
there's an instrumental there's an
instrumental force empowering it, which
is, like I said, why in other countries,
Poland and Hungary, it's not an issue.
and uh you know they c it can be fixed
or I mean it's not going to be easy now
obviously but something can be done if
the actual elected officials cared to do
it but they don't
>> so but so you've used the example of
Poland or Hungary and they're relevant
but don't you think part of it as well
Raymond is for one of a better term
white guilt you know we went the British
went out we colonized we colonized a lot
of these countries and a lot of the
Islamic immigration into the UK is from
Pakistan and Bangladesh both former
colonies. So that must play its own role
as well.
>> Oh yeah, the white guilt. But I mean
that is to me the most contemptable of
all factors that really needs to go
away. This white guilt I never
understand it. Um you know I I did a
recent like study about because we have
Columbus Day here and all these people
get up and oh you know himing and hawing
oh horrible Columbus and what he did to
the natives etc. In fact and Muslims are
doing this too. And my point is like
talk about living in glass houses all
their heroes did far worse than
Christopher Columbus. So my point is
whatever the white man's guilt
>> it's it the same thing's been done to
him and to everyone else okay whites
were enslaved by blacks
>> whites were in you know uh conquered and
I told you Muslims Moors as they were
known from North Africa because of their
dark skin went all the way to Iceland
very fair people and enslaved them in
the 1500s and in there in by England
there was a little island maybe you know
called Lundy which actually was a haven
of barbar pirates who would
raid and enslave British people. So my
point is this white guilt is really
manufactured and it needs to be you know
seen for what it is. If anything I mean
being objective I was just telling you
that the colonial era which is the white
man they actually okay you can say they
conquered uh whatever the Muslim world
India deep into Africa but they actually
brought good stuff with them. Okay, this
which is why the native population
speaks well about that time like they
brought science and technology and you
know literacy, medicine etc. Okay, what
did now the other people we're talking
about that conquered including the
conquered Europeans brought nothing but
death, destruction and slavery. Okay, so
when it's all said and done I don't
think there's much for the white man to
really feel guilty about. And I say this
as a guy as a guy who doesn't think of
himself as white by the way. Okay. So,
I'm just trying to be as objective as
possible and uh and but see the fact
that this exists and I'm glad you
brought it up just shows you how far
gone so many white people are that
they're so caught up in something so
silly that all these other peoples who
are not white would never even think and
shouldn't think of something like that
to actually govern how they see the
world that oh my forefathers did
something so England is bringing
Pakistanis in because they feel bad
because they colonized Pakistan. I mean
that is just such silly and stupid
thinking
>> Raymond and you you use the example and
I mean it was a provocative example of
uh zebras and a lion and then there'll
be people who are listening this or
watching this going yeah but I've got a
Muslim mate he's a nice guy he's like
he's not like that bl you know is isn't
that just a bit reductive and unfair
>> yeah no I'm not saying that uh every
Muslim is a lion who's trying to kill
you what I'm saying is though, let's go
with okay, the most conservative
estimate I've ever heard. I often hear
like 10% of Muslims are radical. I I
mean I think and I've heard a lot of
people say it's more than that. Okay,
but let's say 10. I think that's fair.
>> And I think it's important to delineate
what does actually radical mean.
>> Okay. Well, now we're going to go down
another rabbit hole, but so radical,
what it means, what people mean by that
is this is the weird crazy Muslim who's
not not practicing true Islam. He's
doing this crazy violent Islam. Mhm.
>> To me, radical Muslim is just a
fundamentalist Muslim who's following
his religion to a tea. Okay. And the
moderate Muslim in this parlance, which
is not accurate, is supposedly the
Muslim who's who's practicing good true
Islam.
>> To me, the moderate Muslim who exists is
actually the nonchalant Muslim who's not
taking his religion all that seriously.
So, they exist. I do believe that these
two distinctions exist. I just think the
words are uh inaccurate. Okay? It
shouldn't be a moderate and a radical.
It should be a purist and an observant
Muslim which is the radical and the
nonchalant secular cultural Muslim okay
which is the moderate and they exist. So
now let's say these um let's let's say
10% are the observant radicals right
>> and I give you that number because
that's the smallest number I've heard
from people who are serious. Okay.
>> So my point is yeah um but when you
bring in millions of Muslims okay what's
10% of that? I don't know what the
population, let's say England is, but I
know it's
>> four million
>> four million Muslims. Okay, so you have
400,000 radicals, right? So you have
400,000 who might act like a lion and um
so does what does that mean? I I I agree
the other ones don't, right? But you're
taking a chance. It's kind of like
saying um it's kind of like saying, you
know, I'm going to give you a jar of
candy and only 10 10 out of the hundred
10 are poisonous. Big deal. Take a
chance. They taste good. Right now again
all this the these are like you said
reductive analogies and I understand and
I do believe a lot of Muslims who come
especially a lot of them like I said
come from they come from an Islamic
background but they're not observant.
>> Okay. Yeah. I do believe a lot of these
people come to Europe looking just for a
good life um and whatnot and are not
necessarily dedicated to conquering and
and what I've been discussing. I get all
that. But it's it's the numbers and it's
the fact that they don't assimilate and
the fact that if it's 10% 10% is still a
humongous number. If you said it's 4
million, we're talking 400,000. And I
would and again I'm giving you the 10%.
I'm I'm trying to be kind of lenient
here, but I think it's more, you know,
maybe it's 20 25%. Um, and you know this
because if you listen to what comes out
of these mosques, including in the UK,
it's it's the radical variety, that is
to say, the accurate variety. So um yeah
I so this is what makes this kind of a
quagmire and not an easy thing
especially from the western liberal
mentality which wants to help the
underdog and in fact there is some a lot
of them are underdogs but it comes with
a risk and the risk is what you see
happening in the UK which is once in a
while a Muslim man gets up and stabs
children and people and just uh drives
his truck into some Well,